[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Can you please give
a warm welcome to Adrian Martin?
[APPLAUSE]
ADRIAN MARTIN: OK.
Guys, thank you so, so much
for coming along today.
I can't believe
the crowd in here.
It's mad.
I suppose I wanted to
talk to you a little bit.
So you've got a copy of my
book, and you've probably
been flipping through
it a little bit.
So I'm going to talk about
that in a little bit.
But firstly, I just wanted
to talk about, I suppose,
my story and my background.
Because this is one thing I
get asked about all the time.
I get told very, very
regularly I look about 16.
Right?
I get told that nearly
every day of my life.
I'm 25, believe it or not.
And I suppose my thing-- and
with the Leaving Cert results
that came out yesterday--
we'll go into that
in a little bit.
But about eight years ago,
I completed my Leaving Cert.
Before that, my
interest was always
in food and in cooking and
in all that kind of stuff.
Looking back to when
I was 14, I worked
in this little SuperValu.
I'm from Cavan, OK?
So I'm from a little village
called Bawnboy in Cavan.
The biggest town near there
is called Balleyconnell.
Yeah.
It's a great little
village where I live in.
But my thing was always--
I always had this
interest in food.
So my first job was cleaning
toilets, washing cars,
and sweeping floors
in the SuperValu.
So that was my first job ever.
And I've always been a big
believer in the wheel that
squeaks the most gets the oil.
OK?
So believe it or not,
I'm the squeaker.
I literally believe that
if I can't get something,
I will try my best to get it.
So when I was working in
SuperValu, I was at the manager
every single day.
So this was my
little part-time job,
14-year-old in on a Saturday.
Sunday, I was like, I want to
get in on the delicatessen.
I want to do a little
bit of cooking.
And the manager would
always be like, no, no.
You're going to go in
there and make a mess.
So I got fed up asking because
I asked every single day.
And I walked in--
let's be honest.
I walked out of the job and
walked down to a restaurant
down beside me.
Well, I didn't walk.
Actually, my dad
dropped me down.
And it's a bit far.
It's about half an hour
away from me into Blacklion.
And the chef that ran
that restaurant there
was Neven Maguire.
So I walked up to the door
to Neven, 14-year-old.
I was knocking on the door.
I was like, Neven, give
us a job, will you?
Like this.
And Neven was like, you're
a bit young, inexperienced.
I was like, I have a
mad interest in food.
Please, can I
train to be a chef?
I'm really interested in it, and
I've always watched it on TV.
My obsession, actually, on
TV was with Richard Corrigan,
another chef who's opened a
place there in Virginia more
recently, who's,
obviously, fed the queen
and he's cooked for
so many amazing people
throughout the years.
So I was fascinated by him.
The reason my
fascination was with him
was because he was able to get
a load of random ingredients
and make incredible dishes
out of random ingredients.
That was my obsession.
Also, he could
chop like a ninja.
We'd chop, and he
wouldn't-- he'd look away,
and he wouldn't cut
his hand off, right?
So I landed up to
Neven's restaurant.
He gave me the
opportunity to work there.
So I was in secondary school.
The restaurant was open
Wednesday to Sunday.
So after school, on
Wednesday, Thursday,
Friday, I was straight off
to the restaurant there.
My first job was
to peel potatoes.
So 50-kg bags of potatoes.
You were given 50 bags
of 50-kg bags of potatoes
and told, OK, for
the rest of the day,
you're going to peel all those,
like in the army, basically.
That was my first job.
Did you ever see a spinach leaf?
You know the little
stem on a spinach leaf?
Pick the little stem off.
That's the job, OK?
And place it into a container.
So those little jobs were
the first things that I did,
but I had this army
of chefs around me
that were doing
different things.
You'd have one
chef in there that
was cooking steaks and venison
and the most incredible racks
of lamb and stuff.
And you had someone else who was
plating up desserts and doing
all these incredible designs.
You had someone else
who was at the pass,
calling orders and
sending plates away.
And there was so much
action going on around me.
And I was soaking everything up.
I found myself to be
seriously comfortable
in that environment.
I just soaked it up,
and I loved it to bits.
I would go back to school.
When I was in
school, the whole way
through school, to be
very honest with you,
I was probably
the biggest messer
you'd ever meet in your life.
You would not have wanted
me to be in your class.
Let's be very honest, all right?
If you were in a
class with me, a lot
of people that were in
school with me would be like,
god help you if you're
in class with that fella.
All right?
That's the truth.
I had a serious problem with--
I've always had this.
A serious problem with reading.
I've always had help with
reading the whole way
throughout school
and at spelling.
Massive problem with
spelling, as well.
And I'll get into that.
So in my Leaving Cert-- and the
results were out yesterday--
this was the
biggest goal for me.
So throughout 14 to about 17--
I did my Leaving Cert at 17.
And 14 to 17, I
worked continuously
in Neven's restaurant.
I worked my way up, so I got
on to a section of my own,
where I was able to
serve out food myself.
So I was able to basically
hold a full-time job while I
was at school at the same time.
I was able to work
in school-- well, not
really work in school.
Sit in school and go to work.
And when the Leaving Cert
results came out-- so
for my Leaving Cert,
I didn't study at all.
I had no interest in it.
I didn't know exactly
what I wanted to do.
And I just felt like I
was put through a system.
So it was kind of
like, for me, I'm
not an academic person at all.
I find it very, very
hard to sit down
in front of a laptop and
actually type something
or write something at all.
I'm a completely
different type of people.
And that's why I think that this
system didn't suit me at all.
So for my Leaving
Cert, I didn't study.
My first exam was English.
It was very sunny as,
you know, it always
is on the Leaving Cert.
And once I did my
first exam, I sat out
sunbathing after instead of
studying for the rest of them.
So that was kind of my thing.
And when I got my results, which
was yesterday, eight years ago,
and I got 180 points.
OK?
So 180 points in
your Leaving Cert
is, like, some of the
exams, I walked in,
I just wrote the
exam number on them.
Wrote out a few little
lines and walked out.
That was kind of it.
180 points.
Looking at all my friends.
So this was kind of like
a really big low for me
in my life.
It kind of hits you.
And all your friends are
out there celebrating.
They're all going to Trinity.
They're all going to UCD, DCU,
going to the Limerick, Galway,
incredible universities.
All out celebrating, drinking,
they've done a great exam.
But for me, at that
stage in my life,
I was like, what
am I going to do?
All my mates and
everything are out
celebrating that they've got
this incredible opportunity
to go to do exactly
what they want to do.
They can go become teachers.
They can work at incredible
places like Google.
You know?
They could do all
these kind of things.
For me, it was kind of,
I've got one opportunity
and that's cooking.
So I applied to college.
For someone that has 180
points in your Leaving Cert,
to apply to college, you have to
pay your whole way through it.
So I got into a PLC,
which is literally--
you literally do two
days a week and you
work there two days a week
on your days off of work.
But you also go to work and
you work your full-time job,
as well.
So you fund your whole
way through your college.
But in two years
in Enniskillen, in
a small, little tiny
college, I got my papers
to become a professional chef.
So really, it's a
hands-on course.
Everything is literally, you
start with your different types
of cuisines.
You learn how to, I suppose,
butcher up a chicken.
That's like a module, and
you're examined on that.
I know it's really
weird, but those are
kind of things-- filet a fish.
That was also an exam.
You know, that's the exams
that we did in college.
And that was really
hands-on things.
After that, then
I took a big leap.
I applied to a
college in Killybegs.
And I wanted to get myself
a degree in culinary arts.
So I thought this was a
really big step for me.
It was going to be
three days a week,
so I'd miss out on my
Wednesday in work in Neven's.
And I wanted to get
myself a degree,
because the papers
were great and I'd
be able to teach,
actually, cooking.
So I took the leap on
it and did my exams.
Obviously, when you're in
a small, little college
like that, your lecturers really
pay great attention to you.
So each module that I did--
for instance, we did French.
It wasn't just French
to learn the language.
It was French that we
learned the language of food.
So we learned all about
food but in French.
And our exam was
we had to present
a region all about the food of
a particular region in France.
So I picked Normandy,
because I love it
because of all the
different types of cheeses
and the calvados,
the apple brandy.
You know, all the
different types
of cuisines that are in France.
That was an exam for my
college in Killybegs.
So when I did that, I passed
all my exams, believe it or not.
Very, very lucky to do it.
Got myself my degree and
I came to a crossroads.
So you're working in a kitchen
at the hours of, like, 70 hours
a week, maybe 80 some weeks.
You're in at 9 o'clock
in the morning.
You're finished at
1:00 in the morning.
OK?
You eat your dinner
while you're standing up,
but also you're keeping
an eye on your section.
And you're making sure
that everything's OK.
You're ready for that
service that night.
Because believe it or not, in
Neven's restaurant at the time,
coming to the time that
I was doing my degree,
we were voted 15 best
restaurants in Europe.
OK?
So that's why the
standards were so high.
We were serving food
to such high standards
that you had to be so
well-prepared in advance.
So the hours are really tough.
You're sleeping there.
So you've got a room
in the restaurant,
out the back of the restaurant.
They're not the greatest
rooms ever, let's be honest.
They weren't very nice to live
in, but that's where we stayed.
So you lived this life of
working in this restaurant.
And when I finished my
degree, the crossroads
was either-- all my friends
were chefs, because that's
who I socialized with.
It came to a crossroads where
either I go to Australia--
Melbourne had an amazing
food scene at the time.
And there was Michelin
star restaurants and stuff
that all my friends were
going out there to work in.
And I had applied for a
visa, but I let them all go.
I stayed in Ireland
and I took a chance.
And it's probably
a chance that I--
that crossroads where I came
to, when I made that decision,
it's one that I am
really, really thankful
that I stayed here for.
And I decided that because I
had a degree in culinary arts.
I learned so much about
product development.
I learned so much about, I
suppose, just food, in general,
and the different types
of jobs that are in food.
So I was always taught that
the only job that I could do
was be a chef in a restaurant.
That was kind of it.
But outside of that,
believe it or not,
there's product
development, there's
teaching in cookery schools,
there's endless jobs in food.
And so I decided that I would
offer my services to businesses
all across Ireland.
So I just took a chance,
started sending emails.
Started picking up the phone
and ringing people and saying,
you know, I worked in this
restaurant with Neven Maguire.
He's Ireland's most
well-known chef.
I can come in and maybe
do product development
with your business.
Maybe help you guys out in
some way, developing new menus,
working with you and
all that kind of stuff.
And I basically
offered it for nothing.
So I was like, I'll do
it for 100 euro a week,
and I'll give you
all my recipes,
and I'll give you all my ideas.
And that's kind of--
as long as you let me
stay with you, you know?
That's kind of the way
I put it with them.
And I started in
Bandon, in Cork.
So that was my first business.
It was actually butcher shops.
It was cafes.
It was artisan food stores
and other restaurants
that I worked with.
I had businesses, all together,
that I traveled around Ireland
to.
I worked in every single
county, believe it or not.
128 businesses
altogether I worked with.
So a week, maybe three days
here, three days there,
traveling.
Completely broke.
I had no money.
But it was a chance
that I wanted
to take to get my
name out there.
The beauty about it was
that I got the interaction
with their customers.
I got to meet so many different
types of people, which
brought me out as a person.
So when you leave
a kitchen, you look
like, I suppose-- there's
white walls everywhere.
There's no windows.
You're very pale in the face.
Your eyes are-- you
look wrecked, basically.
You look shattered
coming out of there.
So when I came out of the
kitchen, my communication
skills, literally,
I didn't have any.
They were nonexistent.
You know, you're so
focused on your job
that I needed to improve
on my communication skills.
So that was one
thing that I found.
Traveling all across
Ireland really
brought me out as a person.
Really brought me out to be
able to get out there and speak
to people.
Because at the end of the day,
I was kind of put in a box
and felt like I was very
uncomfortable in speaking
with people.
So once I traveled the
country, I got very lucky.
I got asked to go in
and meet students.
I got asked to go in and do
demonstrations in schools.
I got asked to do demos
at food festivals,
at agricultural shows,
all that kind of stuff.
And I found myself to be
very comfortable doing this.
I enjoyed getting up
in front of a crowd.
I can get up in front of
a crowd like you guys here
today and talk.
But when I have food,
it's kind of like I'm
taking people on a journey.
So it's kind of like
I've got food here,
but you're also with
me and you're, like,
in on the experience, but
only you in the room can
feel that experience.
And that's kind of
the thing that I
feel when I do a cooking demo.
And so I find myself to
be very, very comfortable.
I got very used to
going around to schools.
I traveled around to
secondary schools.
I actually got
picked up by so many
different secondary
schools all across Ireland,
doing talks on healthy eating,
doing talks on, I suppose,
how to cook from scratch.
My age group, believe it or
not, lost out on cooking.
25 to 35-year-olds,
9 out of 10 of us
actually can't cook at all.
It's actually proven in Ireland.
The reason for that was
the Celtic Tiger, the boom.
Our parents were
literally spending money
on literally just, I suppose,
ready meals, eating out a lot
more, and weren't
interested in cooking.
Cooking is a thing that's
passed down by your parents.
It wasn't passed down
to my generation.
I'm just lucky that I trained
in it so I know how to cook.
But my mom wouldn't
have passed it
down to my brothers
or sisters who
are around the same age as me.
So 9 out of 10 of us
can't cook at all.
So I thought, schools,
this is a great opportunity
to get in here, make
sure that doesn't
happen to the next
generation coming through.
So traveling so
much around schools.
Got picked up one
day by the TV3.
It was a show called
"The Late Lunch Live."
It's now called-- well, it
was "The Seven O'clock Show."
Now it's "The Six O'clock Show."
They can't make up their mind
for what it's really called.
But it was giving me
an opportunity, really,
to get on television and
actually cook on television.
And it was on my 23rd birthday,
so it was two years ago,
the 9th of October.
And I cooked which Sharon
Corr and Lucy Kennedy.
So shaking like mad and
getting up there and doing it.
But I've been a regular on
the show there ever since,
for two years now.
And it's just been an incredible
experience for me in there,
and it was a great platform
for me to really improve
on what I did.
Believe it or not,
so you see the way
I call myself Chef
Adrian, the name
came from when I came
to the crossroads.
I said I'd set myself up
a little Facebook page
and document all my travels.
I didn't know what to call it.
I documented all my
travelings through it
and through, I suppose,
YouTube and through Twitter,
and through loads
of different places.
And the reason for
it was-- you ever
see Gordon Ramsay is called
Chef Ramsay in America?
And I was like, that
sounds kick-ass, you know?
So I was like, I'm going
to call myself Chef Adrian,
and it stuck.
And believe it or not,
I actually hate it now,
but I'm not allowed
to remove it.
They won't allow me
to remove it anymore.
But that's kind of stuck
and that's been it.
Yeah.
It's kind of been a journey that
I took through social media.
Gathered together
followers in social media,
got picked up by TV.
Believe it or not, my biggest
break was about two years ago.
That was the start of it.
About two years ago,
I made a recipe.
I was in a school and
the kids were all like,
Adrian, why don't you do
recipes for doner kebabs?
Why don't you do
recipes for spice bags?
Because this is all
that we're eating.
I was like, OK.
So I made a little video
with my own camera at home.
It was literally the
cheapest little Canon camera
you could ever buy,
believe it or not.
And I edited it myself on
my own thing, uploaded it
onto YouTube, and I got such a
massive response to this video.
So all of a sudden, RTE came
to me and were like, Adrian,
we love your video.
Come in here and
make a show with us.
Lovin Dublin were like,
Adrian, come in here
and do some work with
us and everything.
Absolutely everything
exploded from this one video.
It was a spice bag I
made, believe it or not.
So it was actually
a 30-second video
that literally opened a whole
world that I'd never thought
I would have seen, ever.
So I started making
videos for Lovin Dublin.
So all the small, little,
tiny, little Tasty videos?
Those are my hands.
And I didn't believe
that that was actually
a business in food itself.
So the idea that the book--
so I released a show.
I just took the idea from
the students themselves.
They were like, to me, as
you can see, why don't you
do recipes for spice bags?
Why don't you do
recipes for stuff
that we're actually eating?
In Ireland, at the moment,
we're spending $9 million a week
on takeaways.
We are.
Which is a lot.
Yeah.
It is a lot, isn't it?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADRIAN MARTIN: $9 million
a week on takeaways.
That's a lot, isn't it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADRIAN MARTIN: It is a lot.
So the majority of
that would be pizza,
actually, believe it or not.
Yeah.
Pizza is the majority of that.
Well, the idea of the
book was literally
that we'd get students--
so this is what they're eating--
chicken filet rolls,
doner kebabs, spice bags,
all that kind of stuff.
Show them how to
make it themselves,
get them a little bit
interested in food.
But believe it or
not, it wasn't just
students that were
eating this food.
It was everyone.
Absolutely everybody
in the country
is eating this kind of food.
My age group's eating
this type of food.
My parents and their
age group are all
eating that type
of food, as well.
So it really fit it
in so nicely for me.
The idea of the book came
to me just about last year.
So all the little
videos were doing great.
We created a little
series on RTE Player,
which was just an
online series, which
was just Fakeaway recipes.
So we had 10 different
style recipes.
They went down the street.
We also, then, created
a show called--
so we wanted to feed
Ireland's obsession with food.
So you know the way there's
restaurants popping up
everywhere that's like,
"this is the best burger you
can possibly get in Ireland."
"These are the best
wings," you know?
This was kind of--
Ireland's obsession
with food was like this.
So we created a show for that.
We just followed along
with what people wanted.
So we created a show called
"Chef Adrian Eats Ireland."
And I went there to find
the best wings, the best
burger, the best ice cream,
you know, whatever it is.
And we created this little
online series with a TV budget
just for RTE player.
And we had six
different episodes.
Obviously, everything
was in there sponsored
and everything by
Carr's Crackers-- mad,
I know, Carr's Crackers.
But it was an opportunity
I was given by them
to create my own little show.
So the book followed
that perfectly.
So it was kind of in sync.
The recipes that we
were cooking on the show
were actually recipes
that are in the book.
Before I explain a little
bit about the book,
I wanted to talk to you.
So before I brought
out the book,
I had to do a little
bit of research.
Ireland is obsessed
with dieting these days.
You've got either-- one
side of the spectrum
is everyone wants to
look like bodybuilders.
They exercise every single day.
They're really
strict on their diet.
And you know, they're out there
going to the gym so often.
But every single post you
run through on Facebook
is somebody's
weightlifting or squatting
or I don't know what it is.
There's that obsession there.
But there's the opposite
side of the spectrum,
where people have absolutely--
and this is where the $9
million spent on
takeaway comes in--
where people have absolutely
no interest in that at all
and avoid it at whatever costs.
So I don't know where--
some people are in the middle.
Some people are fine.
But there's two sides of this
spectrum that are extreme.
So there's that side, and
then there is this side.
So what I was trying to do was--
the book doesn't feed into--
because there's so many healthy
books out there at the moment.
There's so many
fitness books that
feed a diet, a
particular type of diet.
I had no interest
in that at all.
I'm an ordinary, average person.
OK?
I'm in the middle here.
I cook for myself.
I believe that I use the
best quality ingredients
you can possibly buy.
I read a book,
believe it or not.
No, I listened to a book.
Sorry.
I didn't read a book.
And it was called
"The Diet Myth."
Probably the best I've
ever listened to or read.
It explains diets inside out.
I met with the guy
that wrote the book,
and he invited me down to
Cork to meet with a lecturer
down there who travels
the world lecturing
on this kind of thing.
Diets-- the problem is it
is so hard to maintain it.
It's so hard to keep it up.
It's so hard to continuously
be so strict on a diet.
Any diet at all, may
it be, say, you're
eating lentils for
breakfast, lunch, and dinner.
At the end of the
day, lentils are
going to be the
most horrible thing
to eat breakfast,
lunch, and dinner.
And that's an extreme one.
But say if you went
on any type of diet
at all, what happens normally?
You last about, what?
Maximum-- some people
last longer than others.
Some people may only
last two months.
They lose a load of weight
in a short space of time.
They kind of shock their system.
And they end up putting on
what they lost because they've
lost their momentum, and they've
lost interest in the diet
because it's so
hard to maintain.
Basically, sums up every
single diet out there.
And I have no
interest in telling
you to go out there and
diet and go out there and do
that kind of thing.
So I kind of explain, in the
book, a little bit about that.
All we need to do is look at
the way our grandparents, back
in the '80s, early
'90s, used to cook.
They used to use the best
of quality ingredients
you could possibly buy.
They cooked with cream.
They cooked with butter.
They cooked with oils.
They cooked with the best
Irish ingredients you can buy,
which is on our doorstep.
So you can walk
into a butcher shop.
When they bought
their meat, they
didn't ask for the
fat to be cut off.
They cooked with it on.
OK?
Because that's a natural fat.
Fat, at the end of the day,
is like an aid in digestion.
The one thing we do
really need to look at
is that processed foods
that we're eating.
So the processed sugars,
the processed fats, as well.
They're kind of
destroying our bodies.
I know this is getting in
a little bit deep about it,
but that's kind of the
ins and outs of it.
If you look at the way your
grandparents used to cook
and you feed that into
your own cooking--
so if you're cooking
a meal during the day,
what way would your
grandparents cook it?
They would literally do it the
most basic methods of cooking,
but it was the most
healthy for us.
A broad range then was
used throughout the week.
You need a broad range of
different types of food
to sustain a healthy lifestyle.
Obviously, we also need a
little bit of exercise, as well.
So if you're not into
running, if you're not
into going to the gym or
anything like that, go out
and just walk.
It's very simple.
Just go on a walk
once or twice a week.
It is what helps you.
I want to feed the
obsession here.
This is the obsession
here that $9 million
is spent on takeaways a week.
I have absolutely no
interest in cooking.
I have no interest
in exercising at all.
So let's create a book
for these guys here.
Let's bring them into the middle
and make them a little bit
healthy and shake
them up a little bit.
That's really what the
idea of the book was.
And there you have it
in front of you there.
And you'll notice that some of
the recipes use full-fat cream.
You'll notice that some of
the recipes use grapeseed oil.
You'll notice that
some of the recipes
use spice combinations
and stuff.
Everything is home-cooked.
That's the idea of it.
It's not processed.
You're buying the best
of quality ingredients
you can afford.
You're cooking a meal that
is really good for you,
but also it's stopping
you from buying $9 million
worth of takeaway
a week every week.
I hope you enjoy it.
It was, to be
honest with you, it
was a dream of mine
to ever do this,
me watching Neven for years.
When I was peeling my potatoes,
and Neven was on-- he's
on his 16th book now.
He's done so many
different TV shows for RTE.
That's kind of like a dream of
mine to do something like this.
Get up and talk
to people like you
and do little bits of things
on TV and stuff like that.
It's always been a dream of
mine, from a 14-year-old,
watching Richard Corrigan
on there and stuff.
One in a million chance
can someone like me
get the opportunity to do that.
I'm so thankful
that I can do it,
and it's actually unbelievable
that I am doing it, as well.
I hope you really,
really enjoy it.
I put my heart and
soul into the book.
I've done so much
research and so much,
I suppose, trial and error,
eating these different types
of dishes and trying to get
the exact replicas in there,
as well.
Give them a little try.
Let me know how you get on.
You can send me, I don't
know, a little picture of how
you get on if you want online.
I've had so many
great responses to it.
Believe it or not, the book
is out now seven weeks,
and it's been the best-selling
cookbook in Ireland
the last seven weeks.
There you go.
[APPLAUSE]
Which is mad.
It's really crazy.
But yeah, that's it, yeah?
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
Well done.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Hey, thanks, Adrian.
That was great.
Thank you very much.
I think our audience will
probably agree with me.
You come across as a
very determined person
and very innovative, as well.
Wouldn't you think so?
With the different
challenges that he faced,
especially after his training.
So I'm very
surprised the cooking
doesn't come from the family.
But where does that
personality trait come from?
Does that come from
someone in your family,
that entrepreneurship?
That very innovative--
ADRIAN MARTIN: Oh, my dad is
heavily involved in business.
So my dad runs an event
management company that sets up
food festivals and stuff.
So he's involved
in food himself.
SPEAKER 1: What are they called?
ADRIAN MARTIN: It's
Martin Event Management.
So he sets up cooking
demo stations and kitchens
and does all that kind of stuff.
So it fit in nicely
that the two of us
get to work together in what
we do, which is bit mad.
SPEAKER 1: And was he doing
that when you were young,
when you were a child?
Or is that something
that came later on?
ADRIAN MARTIN: No, it
actually only came, literally,
when I started up, as well.
He set it up at the same
time as me, and the two of us
kind of coincided and
worked together in that.
So it was really cool.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Great.
Very good.
As usual, I'll ask one
or two more questions,
then I'll hand the
microphone out to you guys.
So this happens to me about
two or three times a week--
and it's not because
I'm a millennial,
because I'm not
really a millennial--
tell us about a time you
had an absolute disaster
of a cooking experience.
ADRIAN MARTIN: I've had loads.
Oh, my god, six years in that
kitchen, I've had so many.
My worst one, I think, I
always look back on it.
So we used to make these
sauces called veloutes.
So Wednesday is
your main prep day.
And your veloutes take in the
space of, like, five hours
to make.
Each veloute is finished
off with a liaison,
which is literally egg yolk
and cream mixed together.
And it gives the veloute a
shine and thickens it naturally.
But what happened to me was
I made all the veloutes.
They were always put in
these little buckets.
There were labeled.
They were placed into
this, like, chiller
first to blast chill them.
And then they were
placed into the cooler.
But while I was pulling them
all out of the blast chiller,
every single one of them
landed on the ground.
So I was standing there
and I was like, oh, no.
There is four
hours of work gone.
So you can imagine-- and
then service is coming.
And you have to try and
make these different types--
prawn veloute, Thai
broth, mushroom veloute
with grated truffle
in there that's worth,
like, thousands of
euros and stuff.
So you can imagine what it's--
it was a 'mare.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
I imagine you got in a bit of
trouble about that happening.
Do we have any audience
questions just yet?
I've got one here.
Here you go.
AUDIENCE: You say we should
cook like our grandparents.
So how do you feel about the
more modernist techniques
that are out there these days?
ADRIAN MARTIN: A lot of the
modern techniques-- obviously,
we cook like our grandparents,
like we look at our ingredients
the same way that
they look at it.
But obviously, the modern
techniques that come in
fit in so nicely
with it, as well.
I believe that if you look back,
it's just really looking back
to basics the way they used
to shop rather than cook.
But the modern
techniques of cooking,
using different types of
spices and seasons and stuff,
are absolutely brilliant.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: And back over here.
ADRIAN MARTIN: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ADRIAN MARTIN: I love
all these questions.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Hi.
Yeah, my question is what,
from a personal point
of view, what kind of advice
you would give someone who's
doing the same
thing you're doing,
like kind of becoming a
chef, but hasn't found
the motivation yet to be that
determined about, oh, I'm
setting up my career here?
So is there anything-- maybe
you had a moment yourself
where you were like, oh, no.
ADRIAN MARTIN: Yeah.
Honestly, six years
in Neven's kitchen,
when you're coming
to the end of it,
I was literally just
exhausted and tired
and needed something new.
Six years is a long time
to stay in any restaurant.
Normally, chefs only stay for
about half a year to a year.
All I recommend doing, really,
is traveling around as much
as you can and
picking up as much
as you can from
different restaurants.
I actually worked in here
for about a six-month stint
in Bon Appetit.
It was actually when
I worked in Neven's.
We were sent off to
Michelin-star restaurant
to actually learn about
Michelin-star food.
So I headed up pastry
there for about six months,
which is kind of like--
as I always say-- change
is as good as a rest.
It really helped me.
I also went over, then,
to work in Ramsay's place.
Best meal I've ever had.
I was there for,
like, three weeks.
So you can do stages in there.
It's in Royal Hospital Road.
He has three Michelin stars.
And you know I was
saying, I'm a believer
that the wheel that squeaks
the most gets the oil.
I was literally the
most annoying person
ever for those three
weeks in that kitchen.
I'd say they really liked
to see the end of me.
But travel around as much as
you can and get your degree.
But there's loads of
opportunities out there
in cooking itself, not just
being a chef in a kitchen
or running a kitchen.
I'm 25.
Everyone keeps asking
me, why don't you
have your own restaurant yet?
Why don't you have
your restaurant?
There's no point in me having
a restaurant when I'm 25.
I'd be better off having
a restaurant when I'm 35.
So then I have a lot more
experience behind me.
I know exactly what I
want to do at that stage.
Because I'm only
figuring out what
I want to do as I go along now.
AUDIENCE: My question was,
do you have a restaurant?
[LAUGHTER]
ADRIAN MARTIN: I don't.
No, no.
AUDIENCE: And the
second question
is, as you don't have a
restaurant, two or three names
that you suggest to eat in
Dublin that you say, wow.
ADRIAN MARTIN: Oh, OK.
Obviously, The Greenhouse
is absolutely amazing.
Have any of you ever
been to the Greenhouse?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ADRIAN MARTIN: You have?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: Best
restaurant up town.
ADRIAN MARTIN: Yeah.
It's insanely good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADRIAN MARTIN: Did you have
the little beetroot meringues
with the pistachio?
AUDIENCE: I did.
Actually, I did.
ADRIAN MARTIN: I
robbed that recipe.
[LAUGHTER]
That's a great little thing.
That restaurant is insane.
I suppose I would go
outside of Dublin.
I was in the Cliff House.
I actually didn't
think it was going
to be that nice-- the
Cliff House in Waterford.
The best hotel I've
ever stayed in.
If you leave your room,
there's a sensor on the door.
As soon as you leave your
room, these little fairies
come in and make your
bed and everything.
And it has a Michelin-star
restaurant on-site, as well.
It's really, really good.
It's worth traveling there.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Great.
Thank you.
Yeah.
The Cliff House is great.
And they have one in
town, as well, don't they?
Are they linked?
ADRIAN MARTIN: The sister's--
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, the sister.
So while the audience is
thinking of another question,
I read that when
you have time, you
try to get out and do a little
bit of running now and again.
We have any runners
in the audience today?
Yeah, got a few.
ADRIAN MARTIN: Well, they
probably put me all to shame.
SPEAKER 1: That's great.
What's your post-run treat?
ADRIAN MARTIN: I don't know.
I used to have bananas.
I used to play
football as a kid.
I used to eat a banana.
I had two bananas before
a football match years ago
and everything came up.
So I don't like bananas anymore.
I'd recommend a banana.
Just one, not two.
But I don't know--
SPEAKER 1: Is that all?
ADRIAN MARTIN:
--what I normally do.
I normally get this
idea in my head.
I'm kind of a very
fidgety person, always
wanting to move about
and go on the go.
So if I get it in my head
that I'm going for a run,
I'm literally in the
run before I actually
think of what I'm going
to eat beforehand.
And I'm always
just a big believer
in eating your breakfast,
lunch, and dinner.
Eating your three meals,
cooking them yourself,
and eating nicely.
SPEAKER 1: I run so that I
can add in an extra meal.
ADRIAN MARTIN: I like that.
SPEAKER 1: I know what I'm going
to eat before I go for my run.
We have another few
questions over here.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I actually wanted to ask
a bit more about shopping,
because you mentioned
it's very important to buy
good ingredients and things.
And I think it's
often stopped us
from cooking when
you don't have,
at home, some ingredients.
So what is the best advice, how
to organize your shopping so
that you're not really
going with a book
and choosing three items,
but more holistically,
so it kind of gives you
inspiration for cooking?
ADRIAN MARTIN: Yeah.
I put a little section
in the book there.
It's "What to Have
in Your Cupboard."
So there's a selection of
spices and oils and stuff.
If you have-- you can probably
look in your cupboard already.
And you look at that
little list and it'll say--
you can probably look
in it and then be like,
oh, I actually have the
majority of that stuff already.
The book is literally
anything that
is easily accessible, bought,
in all your shops in Ireland.
And for me, when I'm
cooking, I probably
do it the wrong way, which is
a lot more expensive to do.
I buy ingredients every day.
So I go shopping every day.
So if I'm cooking my
meals, the day before,
I'll do my shopping
for just that day.
I'd recommend maybe going on a
Sunday and gathering together.
So you know exactly what
you're making all week
so that you stick to a
plan, more than anything.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADRIAN MARTIN:
Yeah, a little bit.
But I love it.
My thing is if I'm too lazy
this evening to go shopping,
I'll have something
in the cupboard there.
I'll look at the ingredients
and go, right, I can make--
I don't know.
I've got prawns there,
I've got noodles--
like, rice noodles.
Let's make Pad Thai, you know?
Because you'll have
little bits and bobs.
You can always add in different
types of ingredients and stuff.
And that's kind of
the way I look at it.
You can even get creative with
food, have some fun with it,
as well.
If you're too lazy
one of the evenings
to actually do
something, have a look
at what you have
instead of picking up
the phone a dialing Just
Eat, whatever it is.
Have a look at what you have
and I can put money on it,
you can put together something
really fast, really easy.
A lot quicker than takeaway.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for the talk.
Before I worked here, I worked
also in a five-star hotel
and had chefs every day.
And I think you are
the most humble chef
I've ever met, which I think
is really, really cool.
And I have a light question.
What is one thing that you
really dislike, but sometimes
you have to prepare
it for someone else,
but you really hate it?
ADRIAN MARTIN: I don't know.
I don't mind-- what?
AUDIENCE: You hate sushi.
ADRIAN MARTIN: Oh, yeah, sushi.
Yeah.
I've made sushi so many
times, I just can't eat it.
Agh.
No.
No, it's not for me at all.
Sorry.
There are just some
things that aren't for me.
But yeah.
I just think it's--
I don't know what it is.
Just can't get my
head around it.
[LAUGHTER]
What else do I not like?
Banoffee pie because
bananas, you know?
[LAUGHTER]
Anything to do with bananas.
Oh, also, what gets
on my nerves, right,
is do you know when you
have a smoothie and it says,
mango smoothie?
OK?
But they put banana in it?
It's a banana smoothie, come on.
[LAUGHTER]
It just tastes like a banana.
AUDIENCE: How are you doing?
ADRIAN MARTIN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I was giving
a look to your book,
and there is different
kind of food in it.
There's a bit o Italian,
there is a bit of Indian.
So I have two questions.
The first one is, where
do you get inspiration
when you of a new recipe?
And the second question
is, I have a dinner
party coming next week--
[LAUGHTER]
I swear to God.
And I would like to have a
suggestion from your book
for a starter and a main.
ADRIAN MARTIN: OK, OK.
I like that, actually.
So what was the first question?
I've forgotten it.
AUDIENCE: Your
inspiration, where you take
inspiration in the recipes.
ADRIAN MARTIN: The
inspiration behind--
so you see it's all
broken down into chapters?
I've traveled to
all these places
to try all these
different types of food.
You can see, in Japan
there, when I was in Japan,
I got this lovely little
scallop on the street.
I was amazed by it.
It was just this guy who was
standing at this little stall.
He had the shell on the scallop.
He took the coral off and he
had a blowtorch and he just--
sea salt-- blowtorched
the scallop there.
And it was in a--
served, give you a little
fork, and you eat your scallop
on the go, blowtorched scallop.
And I was obsessed with that.
So kind of the inspiration
behind-- you'll
see each recipe has a story.
On top, each recipe has
a little story there.
And there's a pancake in
there called a socca pancake.
So in Nice, there's
Nicoise cuisine.
They have their own
type of cuisine that's
completely different to France.
And they have all their own
different ethnic dishes.
The socca, I was
obsessed with it.
Because in the market
square in Nice,
when you walk into
the market square,
there's this massive line.
And I was like,
what's going on here?
There's this big line lining
up for this type of pancake.
And I walked up.
Anyway, they make it
there at the stall.
It's a little like, I
suppose, bike and cart.
And when they make it, they
mix it up and roll it out.
They place it onto this
little type of cart.
It goes through a pizza oven,
it comes back in seven minutes.
Next thing, this
massive line forms,
and it's this crispy
chickpea pancake.
But every recipe inside
there has a story
of where I've seen
it before and I
wanted to learn how to make it.
And then, what I was
saying was the wheel
that squeaks gets the oil.
When I was in Nice, I was
like, show me how to make that.
I'm not leaving until
you show me how.
You know?
And that's kind of where I
learned my recipes and stuff,
from traveling and all.
For your dinner party--
AUDIENCE: Pick two, please.
ADRIAN MARTIN: Scallops
and black pudding.
Very, very simple
to put together.
It literally takes you, like,
30 seconds to two minutes--
like, two minutes, each
side of your scallop
will cook your scallops.
Black pudding on the same pan.
How many people
have you got over?
Six, is it?
AUDIENCE: Four.
ADRIAN MARTIN: Four.
So literally four scallops each,
four pieces of black pudding.
A Granny Smith apple, which is
sliced up really, really thin,
mixed through your
lamb's lettuce.
Lemon juice, olive
oil, sea salt.
Put that in the middle of the
plate, arrange your scallops.
Make sure you get a lovely
color on your scallops.
AUDIENCE: I asked you for an
easy recipe, a very easy one.
ADRIAN MARTIN: What
else could you do?
So you're-- oh, a lovely
starter-- actually,
it's not in the book, but a
lovely starter you could do--
because we've got
nectarines that
are in season at the
moment, if you get yourself
a little bit of
ricotta cheese, you
get yourself some
sriracha sauce.
Drizzle in some sriracha
sauce into your ricotta.
Lemon juice, pinch of
salt. Mix that together.
Get yourself some
toasted sourdough bread.
Spread that on your
sourdough bread
and get yourself
a dry griddle pan.
And griddle little
segments of your nectarine
or peach and place those
on top with some rocket.
AUDIENCE: Now you're
talking like a chef.
ADRIAN MARTIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You know?
And a little, I
don't know, dessert?
ADRIAN MARTIN: Dessert.
[LAUGHTER]
There's After Eight
cheesecake there.
So I had a big obsession
for desserts in there.
There's After Eight
cheesecake, which is insane.
And also, your main course.
If you're looking at the sides,
have the little try at Easter--
AUDIENCE: It looks amazing.
ADRIAN MARTIN: It
looks good, doesn't it?
There's Hasselback potatoes.
So if you have a little
look at your side dishes,
these Hasselback
potatoes, they're
literally, like, the
most insanely crispy,
fluffy potatoes you'll ever
have in your life ever.
They're really, really good.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ADRIAN MARTIN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm just wondering,
so when I was 15, 16,
I had the urge to
become a chef, as well.
However, my parents--
especially my dad-- was like,
no, you need to go to uni,
and you've got your brains.
And in the Netherlands,
because I'm Dutch,
you have to have
a certain degree
to go into cooking school.
And I was--
I wasn't eligible to go in.
But I'm still doubting
until the day of today
whether I should do
a cooking school.
However, my question to you
is, obviously, you started
when you was really young.
Have you ever felt
like you missed out
on your youth whilst
other friends were doing,
I don't know, going out,
meeting other girls or guys,
going out for drinks?
And I know you're
really passionate,
but I'm just wondering, have you
ever felt like you missed out
or that you wanted to
change to something else?
And what would be
your advice to people
that have had a dream
similar to you, as well,
but couldn't because of, I
don't know, college or whatever?
ADRIAN MARTIN: My thing was--
I suppose I went through
so many different phases
since I was working there.
You go through so many
different emotions
because you're seeing
the same people
every single day of the
week, your 80 hours a week.
So literally, your
emotions change like that.
And yeah.
I went through so many
different kind of emotions.
All my friends--
I have two friends, believe
it or not, now because of it.
Two of my best friends have
stuck with me from school
and literally have been
the best guys to me
and understood that I had
those long hours and stuff.
But the amount of friends that
just literally dropped and left
because, you know,
they were asking you,
oh, we're going here.
Let's go here.
You miss out on everything.
You really do miss
out on everything,
but it was a sacrifice
I had to take.
Looking back,
probably my parents
were the biggest help to me.
They were always
like, oh, just wait
until you get to your future.
You never know
what you could do.
You could be maybe working in a
college as a college lecturer.
You could be maybe--
I don't know.
My dad was always a believer
that if you believe something,
follow through in it, and
it'll work out in the end.
It was a lot of hard
work, long hours.
There's even Bon Appetit.
I will give you an example.
Oliver Dunne was the chef who
trained under Gordon Ramsay.
For six-- I think it was six,
seven months I was there,
every day, I stood
here on pastry.
Oliver stood here, who was
the owner of the restaurant,
and shouting at me,
and gave me abuse,
and told me I'm a f'ing
idiot, and you're a--
whatever-- all day.
So you'd listen to that
all day from someone.
Yeah, it's tough.
It really is a tough career.
It's getting a lot better.
There's a lot more help
out there for chefs.
There's a massive shortage
in them in Ireland.
There's a shortage
of about 5,000 chefs.
And the reason for that,
they blame the qualification
schemes, but it's not.
It's the treatment
that chefs are
receiving in the restaurants.
It's not the way to
treat people at all.
There is a lot more rules and
regulations coming in for us.
Some of the places
are disgraceful.
Let's be honest, having
pots and pans thrown at you
is not very nice.
But obviously, those guys
are being sought after.
But I recommend, if you
want to do something
and you believe that the end
goal is you get an amazing job,
an amazing life, I think
follow through with it.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Very good.
Certainly sounds like there
is room in the market for you
if you feel like--
ADRIAN MARTIN:
There's lots of room.
Loads of room.
SPEAKER 1: There's
one more question
over on this side of the room.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
When you were talking right
now about your experience,
it reminded me
about a movie, and I
wanted to ask you which
are-- like, for example,
for me, the cooking movie
I love is "Ratatouille."
It's my cooking movie.
Which are your favorite
cooking-related movies?
ADRIAN MARTIN: I love--
what have I watched recently?
I'm obsessed with cooking shows.
I watch so many of them.
Have you ever seen
"Man versus Food?"
AUDIENCE: Adam Richman.
ADRIAN MARTIN: Huh?
ADRIAN MARTIN: Adam Richman.
Yeah.
I actually met Adam recently.
He came to Guinness.
I was obsessed with that show.
So when we met Adam, we
were literally like--
[GASPS]
I was literally standing there.
I was like, I
can't speak to him.
But my friend
thought it'd be funny
that we were, like, messing.
We were just like, oh, let's
get him to do the challenge.
But no, he wasn't up for it.
I love so many different
types of cooking shows.
My all-time favorite
cooking show
ever is "The F Word"
by Gordon Ramsay.
Probably the best put
together cooking show ever.
It's so good to watch.
Gordon's such a fast-paced chef.
He's fiery, obviously.
But it's so interesting
to see ordinary people
come in and work
inside his kitchen
and serve food out to an
amazing set of guests and stuff.
It's a really, really good show.
He's also set a new series
out in the US at the moment.
"The F Word" again, yeah.
It's really good.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Great.
Thank you.
So I'll just ask one last
question before we close.
I love that you've
created a book that's
for the people on the
other end of the spectrum
because, like you
were saying, it's
so easy to drop
out of these habits
and stop continuing them.
Have you had any
feedback from people on--
what kind of a feedback have
you had on the book so far?
ADRIAN MARTIN: Well,
thousands of pictures
from actual students,
which I didn't
expect it to be students.
I expected it to be just
mommies, at the end of the day.
But no, students
have picked up on it
and yeah, it's been amazing.
I'm receiving pictures
every single day of recipes
being made from the book.
Oh, I made your-- it was
really delicious, you know?
And that makes my day.
Also, I was a nervous wreck
when the book came out.
Because it's your it book,
so you're shaking and stuff.
So when I walked in to
see it on the shelf, like,
your heart's racing.
But I remember walking in--
and actually, it's funny--
into Eason.
And there was a guy actually
reading it and I was like, oh!
Like, walked away.
[LAUGHTER]
I should've stood beside
him, like, so what you think?
[LAUGHTER]
But yeah, I was a
nervous wreck about it.
Yeah, so I was like--
like, it's either you make it
or you break it with a book.
It's a big risk to do.
And if your book
doesn't do well,
you can say goodbye to
your career, really.
You won't go as
further on as you can.
So it's such a massive
risky thing to do.
I'm just lucky that
it's done so well
and that I've had massive
feedback from everyone.
SPEAKER 1: That's great.
Congratulations.
And I hope that you get a few
photos from the various people
in this room today from taking
your recipes home with them.
Thank you so much for coming
in to speak to us today.
ADRIAN MARTIN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]